don't worry nobody watches this stupid
show glow in the distance so in May 2019
reddit user vidi NX petitioned noted
youtuber mr. beast to plant 20 million
trees to celebrate reaching 20 million
subscribers on his YouTube channel mr.
beast then partnered with other noted
youtuber Marc roba to launch team trees
aiming to raise 20 million dollars
before 2020 which would then be used to
plant 20 million trees the project
spread widely across social media and
with large donations coming in from
people such as PewDiePie Susan Wojcicki
and budget Tony Stark they hit their
goal it's been estimated that team trees
will remove over a million tons of
carbon and over a thousand tons of air
pollution from the atmosphere
reforesting areas that have lost tree
cover due to wildfires and logging I
have mixed feelings about the project
not however for the following reasons
number one the ecological effects of
planting these trees I'm sure that they
will bring restoration to damaged biomes
number two the stewardship of these
trees I have no doubt that they will be
managed and planted in a sensible way
and number three the carbon sink of
these trees removing a million tons of
carbon from the atmosphere is definitely
a good thing as we've seen adding a lot
of carbon to the atmosphere on short
timescales results in pretty significant
anthropogenic global warming no I
believe about teen trees have the
potential to do real damage because of a
concept called self licensing the
problem isn't with the trees it's with
people let me tell you something
surprising research has shown that when
consumers buy energy-efficient products
they actually end up increasing their
energy usage this is because they use
them more frequently than they were
using their previous more energy
inefficient products so people that buy
energy-efficient lightbulbs will leave
the lights on for longer than people
with older light bulbs people who add
more insulation to their house leave the
heating on for longer than people who
have old drafty houses while each
individual you use
of their new product may have a lower
energy use associated with it more
frequent use of those products will
result in more energy being consumed
overall self licensing is the phenomenon
of people subconsciously overestimating
that good a positive action has in
wiping out negative actions so for
example people who have a diet soda with
their fast-food subconsciously think
that the calories saved by having a diet
soda justifies the extra calories that
they have in the fast-food people who
save money on small regular purchases
subconsciously justify treating
themselves to some luxury item which
results in more money being spent
overall than they say I want to be very
clear that team trees in isolation will
have a positive impact on the ecosphere
the problem is that it doesn't exist in
isolation and that people don't make
rational decisions I do that
my problem with team trees is that
people very well-intentioned people
signed up to support this project which
will have a positive impact on the
environment but they overestimate how
much good the project will do and those
same people may in the absence of the
project existing have made lifestyle
changes which would have had a much
larger positive effect on the
environment because remember there are
two approaches to this problem and the
pretended climate change is a thing
because humans have put carbon into the
Earth's atmosphere and keep adding more
and more carbon every year so there's
two approaches to fix this you could
either suck carbon out of the atmosphere
that we've put there or you can start
putting so much carbon in the atmosphere
in the first place by signing up two
team trees people are subconsciously
justifying not changing any of their
other behaviors behaviors which emit a
huge amount of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere how much well let's compare
the carbon capture of team trees with
the impact of individual actions let's
say that you made a middle-of-the-road
of $20 verse planting 20 trees now that
according to the figures that team trees
give will sequester 1.6 tons of carbon
which is equivalent to 5.9 tons of
carbon dioxide because obviously
karpin's only part of that molecule and
that is sequestered in the ground over
the lifetime of those trees which
according to the figures they give is
assumed to be 100 years assuming 3%
mortality rate compare this to the
impact of changing your diet a recent
study found that an average meat-eater
consuming 2,000 calories per day has a
footprint of 5.6 3 kilograms of co2 per
day while a vegetarian consuming the
same number of calories had a footprint
of 3.8 1 kilograms per day or Quigley 2
tonnes per year versus 1.4 tonnes per
year so by being veggie for 10 years
you are saving approximately the same
amount of carbon that your trees will
pull down in their lifetime over a
century and if you are vegan rather than
veggie and thus emitting around a ton of
co2 per year that time period goes down
to just 6 years or let's compare that to
flying if you fly a return journey from
London to New York you will emit around
1 ton of carbon dioxide if you fly from
London to LA you will admit around 1.6
tonnes or in other words if you do 4
return journeys from Western Europe to
the western seaboard of America in your
lifetime then those 4 actions alone will
have produced as much carbon as your 20
trees will have pulled down in their
lifetime if you donated to team trees
then I applaud you I applaud mr. beast
and Mart Rover for setting it up it is a
good thing to remove a million tonnes of
carbon from the atmosphere what I'm
trying to say is that firstly a million
tonnes is really not that much
considering that we emit 10 billion
tonnes of carbon into the atmosphere
every year and that be you do not have
carte blanche to continue emitting
carbon dioxide with all of the choices
you make in your life like your diet and
your travel
just because you planted a few handfuls
of trees yes you did a good thing but
don't let the self a licensing effect
blind you to the actual data the fact is
that while team trees is a carbon sink
and so a step in the right direction
it's frankly a tiny one if you have a
runaway train firing a super soaker
otter is technically a step in the right
direction but a much better one would be
to apply the brakes cutting your
emissions by making simple lifestyle
changes like not eating beef the worst
carbon footprint of any foodstuff or
flying once less per year when added up
over the course of your lifetime or even
just a couple of years will make a
significantly bigger positive
contribution to the environment
simply put reducing the amount of carbon
that we put into the atmosphere is more
efficient than sucking carbon out of it
of course these approaches are not
mutually exclusive a great phrase is
that there is no silver bullet to stop
climate change only silver buckshot
scaling-up afforestation on its own is
simply not going to work if you forested
every square meter of America and China
you would offset roughly 50 years of our
current level of emissions nevermind the
historical emissions and man-made carbon
capture technology is still completely
economically unviable the scale required
what we need to do is both suck carbon
out of the atmosphere with stuff like
afforestation and man-made carbon
capture but also much more importantly
reduce our emissions and reduce the
amount of carbon we're putting in the
system in the first place through
individual actions like changing our
diet and the way that we travel but also
larger scale actions like lobbying
corporations to be carbon neutral or
carbon negative and transitioning on
national energy supplies away from
fossil fuels towards renewables which
are cheaper anyway my beef of team trees
is that it can make people think it is
ok to not take these action
like people supporting a project with a
small positive impact they feel
overconfident about the good that they
have done for the environment and
therefore won't make changes on an
individual basis like flying less like
changing their diet which when added up
over a couple of years would have had a
much larger impact overall I wanted to
make this video to put this data out
there and stop people from feeling
overconfident in the contribution they
have made I'm not trying to put down
what team trees has done as I've said
carbon capture by afforestation
needs to be part of our silver buckshot
we need those negative emissions what
I'm trying to say is that it's nowhere
near as important as reducing our
current active emissions if you want to
combat climate change that is what you
what we need to do I really hope that
you took something away from this video
mr. beast mark if you are watching then
I just like to say I think what you are
doing is a good thing I am NOT trying to
put it down I'm just trying to put it in
data context but if you the viewer took
something from this video then do pop it
alike if you think other people should
see it then please do give it a share
and if you'd like to learn more about
why f-4s station isn't the answer to
climate change on its own then check out
a video up here from fantastic climber
Adam and if you'd like to learn more
about what you can do to combat climate
change then check out my video on the
subject down here I look forward to the
comments being completely civilised on
this one thanks very much for watching
and I'll see you in the next one